[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravie de vous retrouver
sur le plateau de Parlement Hebdo
l'essentiel de l'actualité à l'Assemblée
nationale et au Sénat nouvelle saison
avec Alexandre Poussard bonjour
Alexandre bonjour Invité et notre invité
pour commencer cette nouvelle saison de
Parlement hebdos et Roger carochi
sénateur les républicains des
Hauts-de-Seine vice-président du Sénat
et Roger carochi vous connaissez bien le
Parlement car vous avez même été
ministre en charge des relations avec le
Parlement c'était sous le mandat de
Nicolas Sarkozy bonjour Roger
cette semaine on va parler bien
évidemment des retraites Emmanuel Macron
a relancé la réforme l'idée de la
réforme en tout cas suscitant des remous
y compris au sein de sa majorité
Elisabeth borne a rencontré les
parlementaires pour tenter de déminer le
terrain
faut-il ou non taxer les profiteurs de
crise au nom de la solidarité nationale
c'est la Question à la Une à l'Assemblée
ou la mission chargée du dossier à
auditionner le PDG de Total énergie
et puis Gérald Darmanin auditionné sur
le projet de loi d'orientation et de
programmation du ministère de
l'Intérieur un texte à 15 milliards
d'euros qui arrivent dès le 11 octobre
au Sénat
et on commence par la réforme des
retraites les présidents de groupe
parlementaires étaient reçus mercredi à
Matignon par la première ministre
Elisabeth borne et pour les oppositions
il est hors de question de passer en
force cette réforme des retraites durant
l'automne Samia de cher comment faire
passer la réforme des retraites
l'exécutif va-t-il jouer la carte rapide
d'un amendement au budget de la Sécurité
sociale à l'automne ou prendre le temps
d'un projet de loi en 2023 après deux
jours de consultation les présidents des
groupes parlementaires ne sont pas plus
avancés sur le sujet
dans un sac c'est à dire on sait pas on
sait pas on sait pas comment les la
question des retraites va être traitée
Matignon n'a visiblement pas encore
tranché et sa majorité s'impatiente ce
qu'on a dit collégalement c'était qu'il
fallait qu'il y ait une décision rapide
qui puisse être prise parce qu'au-delà
de la méthode qui sera décidé ce qui
nous importe c'est surtout le fond
c'est-à-dire pourquoi on doit
impérativement mener cette réforme mais
la méthode précisément fait débat chez
les alliés de la majorité on est
d'accord sur la nécessité d'une réforme
ensuite sur la forme je dirais on en
discuter voilà tout comme le modem la
droite est favorable à une réforme des
retraites mais refuse qu’elle soit
adoptée par un simple amendement au
projet de loi de finances de la sécurité
sociale une réforme des retraites ne se
fait pas quand on est le gouvernement
par un abonnement tombé au dernier
moment en se passant de la vie du
Conseil d'État et de l'étude d'impact et
sans aucune concertation même son de
cloche à gauche où l'on se prépare déjà
au combat en cas de passage en force de
la réforme des retraites au Parlement
évidemment
un casus Belly et une violence faite au
débat parlementaire autant que le
dialogue social donc sur la forme
évidemment pour nous on n'était pas on
n'était pas question on a notamment
alerté la première ministre sur le
risque que pourrait prendre le
gouvernement à passer en force ou à
passer par la petite porte parce que ça
soit par le 49-3 ou via des amendements
dans le PLF sur sur les retraites c'est
totalement inacceptable le risque du
passage en force au Parlement par
l'article 49-3 c'est quand l'absence de
vote l'opposition n'est plus d'autres
choix qu'une motion de censure pour
faire barrage au texte Marine Le Pen s'y
prépare déjà je lui ai clairement dit
que s'ils entendaient faire passer la
réforme des retraites par
l'intermédiaire d'un amendement au
projet de loi de finances de la sécurité
sociale et en utilisant le 49.3 alors
nous déposerions une motion de censure
et nous noterions l'émotion de censure
qui serait déposée quelle que soit leur
origine le projet de loi de finances de
la sécurité sociale sera présentée en
conseil des ministres lundi prochain il
y aura-t-il un amendement sur la réforme
des retraites Emmanuel Macron veut aller
vite celui qui tranchera au final sur la
méthode Roger carotier on va commencer
par une question simple si le
gouvernement souhaite reculer l'âge de
départ à la retraite 17 automne dans le
budget de la Sécurité sociale est-ce que
vous voterez cette réforme
moi j'adore le texte quand même pardon
de vous le dire comme ça chacun sait que
aux républicains nous sommes favorables
à une réforme des retraites avec
l'allongement de la durée de cotisation
et le décalage au moins 64 ans donc sur
le fond n'est pas d'état d'âme à voter
une réforme qui irait dans ce sens mais
je suis méfiant
je vous rappelle que le président Macron
avait désigné Jean-Paul Delevoye qui
pendant 18 mois avait fait des
consultations puis on nous a dit qu'il y
aurait un texte il y aura pas eu de
texte puis un texte qui est allé à
l'assemblée qui n'est jamais venu au
Sénat on nous a promené sur la réforme
des retraites pendant 3 ans et c'est
rien passé par conséquent je suis
prudent j'attends de voir est-ce que oui
ou non le gouvernement est décidé à
faire un texte mais s'il veut faire un
texte le texte c'est pas très compliqué
à faire il fait un texte il dépose un
texte de projet de loi et on avance pour
le moment on nous dit bah vous verrez
bien il y aura peut-être un amendement
dans le projet de loi de financement la
sécurité sociale ça n'est pas sérieux
ils ont un texte où ils ont pas de texte
Bruno Retailleau a dit qu'une telle
méthode était inacceptable ce n'est pas
tout à fait ce qu'a dit le président du
Sénat Gérard Larcher regardez on va voir
son tweet il dit sur les retraites
piliers sociales le statu quo n'est plus
possible or les intentions du
Gouvernement reste confus c'est un peu
ce que vous dites aussi mais la réforme
est indispensable soit par un texte dans
l'autre projet de loi de financement de
la sécurité sociale soit par un texte
ad-oc juste une question simple est-ce
qu'il y a une différence de ligne au
sein de la droite au Sénat non il y a
pas de différence de ligne nous nous
avons les trois dernières années
déposées des amandes d'appel puisque
toute façon il y avait une majorité
absolue à l'époque à l'Assemblée
nationale donc le gouvernement faisait
ce qu'il voulait et nous avons fait des
amendements d'appel en notamment
décalant l'âge de la retraite mais nous
savons parfaitement que il faut un texte
pourquoi il faut un texte parce que ça
passera par le Conseil d'État et surtout
on aura une étude d'impact on saura
exactement quelles sont les bienfait de
vos amendements d'appels comme vous
dites mais c'est pour ça que je dis le
texte du projet de loi franchement ça
fait cinq ans qu'on travaille dessus que
le gouvernement travaille dessus il peut
faire le texte du projet de loi en 15
jours le déposer au Conseil d'État nous
le faire voter au mois de janvier mais
maintenant qu'on en sorte qu'on arrête
ces bisbilles parce que moi je considère
que ce cirque actuel
on reprend la réforme parce qu'elle est
indispensable mais alors ce qu'on va
faire un amendement et on consulte et on
machin c'est encore du temps perdu ça ça
fait des années qu'on parle de cette
réforme elle est simple à faire qu'on
nous fasse un texte qu'on le dépose
qu'on en débatte et qu'on le vote et
donc selon vous aussi ce texte est
inclus au budget de la Sécurité sociale
et que on le on en débat à l'automne il
y a pas de problème vous le voterez mais
non je vous dis je veux un texte
d'une réforme il faut quand même un
certain nombre d'articles pour prévoir
les carrières longues pour prévoir un
certain nombre de fonctions plus
particulières pour prévoir les cas
particuliers les cas spécifiques dans la
réforme des retraites tout ça c'est déjà
étudié ça a été étudié à plusieurs
reprises dans les cinq dernières années
mais il faut un texte un amendement ou
alors c'est un amendement de 40 pages et
pardon de vous dire ça ne correspond
plus à rien alors je vous propose
justement d'écouter la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale il y a El Brown
pivée qui elle opposée à une réforme des
retraites pas sur le fond bien sûr mais
par voie de cet amendement dont on parle
écoutez il y a El brand Pivet
je trouve que les amendements du
Gouvernement ne doivent pas porter en
eux-mêmes une réforme substantielle donc
pas de passage en forme de cette manière
vous êtes d'accord avec
après il faudrait pas non plus que ce
soit un prétexte pour le gouvernement
pour dire ah on n'est pas voulu d'un
amendement alors la réforme vous verrez
bien un jour si on l'a fait ou on l'a
fait pas un moment ça suffit quoi que le
gouvernement prenne ses responsabilités
je vais vous dire une différence entre
législatif et l'exécutif c'est que
théoriquement l'exécutif et la pour
trancher bah je constate que depuis le
temps on tranche pas sur la réforme des
retraites et je reconnais que c'est
absolument aberrant dans cette réforme
des retraites si le gouvernement utilise
l'article 49-3 de la Constitution qui je
le rappelle permettrait de faire adopter
cette réforme sans vote des députés et
ce que vous seriez choqué en tant que
parlementaire
je suis celui qui a porté la réforme de
la Constitution qui est limitée
l'usage du 49-3 qui autrefois pouvait
être utilisé autant que le souhaitait en
2000 et à partir de 2008 on a dit non
c'est texte budgétaire et une fois en
dehors des textes budgétaires donc je
conseille au gouvernement
de limiter au maximum le 49.3 le 49.3 il
va probablement j'imagine l'utiliser sur
le budget mais
chaque fois qu'il utilisera le 49-3 il y
aura évidemment en soubaissement l'idée
qu'il est minoritaire
il passait du passage en force le 49-3
c'est une évidence et s'il le faisait
constitutionnellement la raison la
raison il a le droit mais politiquement
c'est une erreur magistrale et parce que
dans une période où tout le monde dit le
président de la République n'est pas
très populaire l'assemblée n'a pas de
majorité absolue faire du 49-3 ça donne
vraiment le sentiment que voilà
après nous le déluge et on constitue une
constitutionnellement la droite devrait
voter une motion de censure
moi je serai député moi je serai député
républicain et passerateur
une motion de LFI ça pourrait un peu mal
au cœur de la beauté voilà je le dis
franchement je veux dire on peut ne pas
être d'accord avec le gouvernement de la
aller voter à moins que le groupe LR
dépose une motion lui-même auquel cas on
verra bien qu'il avait mais moi ça me
fait mal au cœur de votre émotion elle
est fi je le dis en tout cas vous êtes
bien sénateur LR et vous allez répondre
à cette question faut-il ou non taxer
les super profits une mission
d'information flash c'est à dire qui
travaille en un temps plus rapide a été
créé à l'Assemblée elle porte
précisément sur les profits
exceptionnels réalisés par les
entreprises pétrolières gazières et
maritimes le PDG de Total énergie a été
auditionné Clément Méric
taxer les super profits face au MEDEF
Bruno Le Maire a d'abord ironisé je ne
sais pas ce que c'est qu'un super profit
mais la première ministre s'est montré
plus prudente tout va dépendre des
efforts consentis par ces entreprises
sur les salaires et sur les prix
[Musique]
je pense que les entreprises vont faire
peur de responsabilité preuve de
responsabilité si certaines ne le
faisaient pas nous ne fermons pas la
porte
à l'Assemblée l'aile gauche de la
majorité c'est elle-même interrogée en
juillet lors de l'examen du projet de
loi de finance rectificative mais la
ligne semble désormais claire si on taxe
en France mais que les activités vont
ensuite s'installer en Belgique ou en
Allemagne c'est mauvais pour nos
finances publiques ces mauvais pour
notre économie et scène résous rien il y
a une proposition qui est faite au
niveau européen elle
recueille tout notre intérêt
[Musique]
ce mécanisme européen c'est celui que
des fentes Emmanuel Macron mais la nupes
elle préfère une contribution immédiate
au niveau national elle a lancé cette
semaine une procédure de référendum
d'initiative partagée sur ce sujet
qu'on vous parle d'une contribution
provisoire sur des profits exceptionnels
qu'on vous parle en fait de taux qui
sont des taux progressifs on vous parle
de prendre 15 à 20 milliards d'euros sur
des entreprises qui a une phase de 174
milliards d'euros de bénéfices et donc
nous on va dire que quand c'est trop on
est là pour prendre notre dîme au
passage voilà le rassemblement national
se dit prêt à signer cette proposition
de référendum mais le RN voudrait aller
plus vite nous on le redéposera en
amendement je pense qu'il la nuit pêche
le fera aussi pourquoi car la difficulté
du référendum que vous proposez même si
sur le principe que je ne suis pas
contre c'est la temporalité le temps que
ce référendum se mette en place et pour
peu qu'il se mettent en place le sujet
promet donc de longs débat lors de
l'examen du projet de loi de finance dès
le mois d'octobre
est-ce que vous êtes de ceux qui
estiment qu'il faut taxer les super
profiteurs de crises qu'il faut prendre
notre dîme au passage comme lundi à
l'instant Olivier Faure
du 18e siècle au profit du clergé donc
on va peut-être pas revenir sur la dîme
moi je ne suis pas
systématiquement opposé à ce qu'il y ait
un impôt supplémentaire lorsqu'il y a
des profits considérables
supplémentaires profit qui se font sans
qu'il y ait la moindre action
d'investissement ou la moindre action
industrielle d'une société je suis pas
hostile sur le principe je trouve
qu'après tout tout le monde doit
contribuer en période de crise mais ce
que j'entends est-ce que je vois comme
système de taxation quand j'entendais
aller on va prendre 15 ou 20 milliards
parce que c'est la dîme qu'on prend au
passage ça va on n'est pas des
flibustiers on est là non mais ce que je
veux dire c'est que il faut à la fois se
dire il y a pas la maison qui est des
super profits anormaux et en même temps
se dire qu'est-ce qu'on fait pour
maintenir l'attractivité de nos
entreprises en France pas la peine
effectivement qu'elle s'expatrie parce
que disent la fiscalité française était
étouffante ce qui est déjà le cas nous
sommes déjà les premiers ou les 2e du
monde sur la fiscalité ça n'a pas de
sens il faut trouver un équilibre et je
trouve que des deux côtés ceux qui
disent non pas question comme ceux qui
disent allez on va prendre le pognon des
deux côtés il y a pas beaucoup
d'équilibre voilà un peu d'équilibre de
nuirait pas on peut le faire en accord
avec les grandes entreprises vous savez
du temps de Nicolas Sarkozy parce que
vous avez eu la mobilité de rappeler que
j'avais été ministre de ce temps là
c'est pas si vieux je vous remercie mais
on avait mis une taxation volontaire qui
avait plutôt bien fonctionné bon voilà
moi ça me choque pas mais il faut
trouver une voie d'équilibre donc vous
croyez l'idée d'une taxation volontaire
des super profits c'est à dire que les
grands groupes vont venir et vous dire
voilà nous on veut payer ça parce qu'on
a on a fait trop de bénéfices cette
année si vous pensez que les types ils
vont venir en vous disant on veut en
quoi ça consiste laxation la première
ministre qui avait fait une proposition
que je trouvais plutôt pas mal mais j'ai
cru comprendre que personne la prenait
prenait la balle au bon qui dit bah les
entreprises qui font de super profits si
on voit qu'elle baisse les prix pour les
consommateurs si on voit que ces
entreprises font des hausses de salaire
pour leurs ouvriers leurs employés etc
on considéra qu'elles font des gestes
bon on a cru comprendre que certaines
entreprises le faisaient que d'autres le
faisaient moins et ben on les met autour
de la table on dit bon vous c'est quoi
vos gestes en faveur des consommateurs
vous baissez comment le prix à quel
niveau si on estime c'est suffisant très
bien si on estime que c'est pas
suffisant contribution alors à
l'Assemblée puisqu'on parle de
l'assemblée de la nupes à déposer à
déposer une proposition de loi pour
taxer des super profits elle espère que
ce texte récoltera 4,7 millions de
signatures de citoyens c'est ce qu'il
faut pour faire l'objet d'un référendum
d'initiative partagée
comme on dit en nom de code est-ce que
tout simplement cette démarche peut
aboutir selon vous non parce que
enfin moi je vais opposer sur le
principe de référendum je suis gaulliste
donc je n'ai rien contre la référendum
sauf que on voit bien qu'on est dans le
débat budgétaire dans les semaines qui
viennent que le temps d'avoir 4,7
millions de signatures d'organiser
éventuellement un référendum vous faites
un référendum au printemps au mieux au
printemps c'est-à-dire un moment où le
débat budgétaire est terminé si vous
voulez que ce soit réellement actif
productif et tout il faut une décision
avant Noël il faut que tout soit réglé
avant Noël parce que qui vous dit que
dans un cas de français c'est forcément
dans un cadre budgétaire que le
gouvernement prenne ses responsabilités
bien sûr enfin oui il est ce
gouvernement là on n'arrête pas de nous
dire que alors pour les retraites il
consulte machin il sait pas ce qui fait
un amendement pas un amendement pour le
budget ah bah il faut consulter on sait
pas ce qu'un référendum enfin ça suffit
il y a un gouvernement dans ce pays et
en tout cas Emmanuel Macron il serait
plutôt favorable à une solution
européenne une contribution européenne
sur les super profits qui est demandé
par la présidente de la commission
Ursula vanderline ce serait une bonne
solution selon vous s'ils vont vite
parce que si c'est pour nous dire alors
d'accord il faut consulter les 27 on va
voir si les 27 ans d'accord on va
demander si tout le monde est à
l'équilibre on prendra peut-être une
décision dans 6 mois si c'est ça ça sert
à rien enfin je veux dire à un moment
les profits sont très importants du fait
de la guerre en Ukraine du fait d'un
certain nombre de conditions de
l'inflation qui vous dit que dans un an
ça existera encore parce que si on
arrive à voter ces trucs là dans 6 mois
ou dans un an si ça se trouve la
situation internationale sera totalement
différente et tout le monde dira
éventuellement s'ils veulent une
décision qu'il l'a proposé dans le
budget s'ils n'en veulent pas c'est pas
la peine de faire du cinéma alors Roger
carotte si on va parler de sécurité
maintenant puisque le ministre de
l'Intérieur Gérald de Darmanin était
auditionné cette semaine au Parlement
pour présenter son projet loi
d'orientation et de programmation du
ministère de l'Intérieur donc c'est un
texte qui augmente les moyens des de
l'ordre sur les cinq prochaines années
on va écouter un extrait de l'édition de
Gérald Darmanin au Sénat
au ministère de l'Intérieur la
difficulté est sans doute que pris par
les crises de successives et par
l'actualité nous concentrons sur des
choses à quelques jours à quelques
semaines ou quelques mois mais nous
n'avons besoin sans doute de moyens
budgétaires étendus 15 milliards d'euros
qui sur 5 ans vont permettre une
transformation profonde du ministère de
l'intérieur dont la moitié de ces 15
milliards iront aussi Berre et au
numérique voilà 15 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires 8500 postes de policiers
et de gendarmes qui vont être créés
selon vous ce texte il va dans le bon
sens vous le voterez le 11 octobre le
jour à partir et bien duquel le débat va
commencer sur sur ce texte au Sénat il
va y avoir un travail en commission il y
aura probablement un certain nombre
d'amendements et de modifications par la
commission mais le texte va évidemment
dans le bon sens c'est pas nous qui
allons nous opposer à ce qu'on met des
moyens supplémentaires sur la sécurité
dans le pays on clame suffisamment qu'il
y a une explosion de la délinquance et
une insécurité croissante quand on nous
propose de créer des unités
supplémentaires de gendarmerie ou de
police on va pas dire on va pas dire non
donc forcément moi a priori
j'interviendrai sur ce texte
naturellement je considère que c'est
cette loi va dans le bon sens elle sera
modifiée ici on verra si le ministre
accepte les amendements des commissions
et du Sénat mais le gouvernement a
raison de commencer par le Sénat
parce que ça suffit le bazar nous on
veut travailler ce texte sortir un texte
qui serait un texte acceptable pour tout
le monde et on enverra l'assemblée et on
verra ce qu'elle en fait mais en tout
état de cause il est clair que c'est un
texte important et que c'est un texte
qui va effectivement dans le bon sens
Emmanuel Macron se tarde d'avoir donné
plus de moyens en force de l'ordre que
c'est prédécesseurs et pourtant son
bilan en matière de sécurité ne semble
pas très bien vu dans l'opinion comment
vous l'expliquez pour une raison
extrêmement simple que j'ai déjà dit je
ne sais pas combien de fois tous les
ministres de l'Intérieur successifs
depuis 10 ans il faut qu'ils arrêtent de
nous casser les pièces sur Oui mais du
temps de Sarkozy vous avez réduit et
tout on avait réduit le personnel
administratif de la sécurité et c'était
une époque où il y avait pas cette
tension terroriste ou la délinquance
était en baisse pourquoi est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui les choses ne vont pas
c'est qu'en réalité la hausse des moyens
accordés à la sécurité police
gendarmerie moyen cyber etc et un rythme
plus faible que la hausse de la
délinquance je n'y peux rien la société
de plus en plus violente pas seulement
en France la société de plus en plus
déstabilisée fracturée la hausse des
actes délinquance la violence de ses
actes délinquance à considérablement
augmenté depuis 10 ans et
malheureusement c'est une course
poursuite entre
l'exaspération de la population face à
cette violence et cette délinquance et
la hausse des moyens je dis pas qu'il y
a pas de hausse des moyens depuis 10 ans
qu'elle va moins vite que la hausse de
la délinquance
ça devient
hallucinant enfin clairement bah
j'allais presque dire les délinquants
sont plus modernes et plus rapides que
nous quoi donc il faut mettre les moyens
sur des moyens technologiques modernes
de renseignement de lutte contre la
cyber délinquance comme on l'a fait sur
la
et dans quel sens
sincèrement je pense pas je pense que on
a déjà tous les textes nécessaires qu'il
y ait parfois une erreur d'un policier
très bien il y a suffisamment de
secteurs il y a l'IGPN pour ça il y a
toutes les sanctions possibles mais que
chaque fois qu'il y a d'obtempérer en
mettant en cause les policiers
sincèrement si on veut on peut très bien
leur dire on va vous désarmer on va vous
empêcher de faire les contrôles on va
laisser la délinquance installer et bien
ça n'est pas possible moi j'ai confiance
dans la police de la République et je
souhaite que l'opinion publique
soutienne la police de la République
sinon on en reviendra aura une des gangs
et des bandes et c'est pas ce que
souhaitent les Français on va finir
Roger scarucci cette émission avec un
coup d'oeil à l'ordre du jour à venir à
l'Assemblée nationale et au Sénat voyons
tout de suite les temps forts de
l'agenda parlementaire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et au Sénat mercredi le directeur
général de la police nationale sera
auditionné sur la réforme de la police
une réforme qui crée du mécontentement
parmi les policiers jeudi un rapport sur
l'industrie de la pornographie sera
rendu public par la délégation au droit
des femmes du Sénat une délégation qui a
notamment travaillé sur la lutte contre
les violences sexuelles dans ce milieu
de la pornographie et à l'Assemblée on
en parlait lundi donnera le coup d'envoi
de ce que l'on appelle l'automne
budgétaire l'automne tout court
d'ailleurs puisque l'été c'est fini il y
aura l'audition lundi 26 de Bruno Le
Maire et Gabriel Attal et puis les
députés commenceront à examiner le
projet de loi sur le marché du travail
premier texte de la rentrée à
l'Assemblée une question bien sûr Roger
carochi sur le budget lundi après
l'assemblée les sénateurs vont eux aussi
auditionner Bruno Le Maire donc vous et
Gabriel Attal sur ce budget la bataille
politique est annoncé est-ce que vous
êtes prêts vous sénateur à voter ce
budget en tout cas de ce qu'on en sait
ce que vous serez un allié ou pas du
tout
macroniste primaire mais je suis un
opposant quand vous votez un budget
c'est que vous appartenez ou vous
apparentez à la majorité présidentielle
ou à la majorité gouvernementale
le budget et puis on sait très bien
qu'on va faire un certain nombre de
propositions on aura l'occasion d'en
reparler mais on va faire un certain
nombre de propositions qui vont être
refusés par le gouvernement parce que on
a des différences considérables sur un
certain nombre de thèmes donc comment
voter le budget à la fin non ou alors si
on votera le nôtre de budget
c'est-à-dire le budget totalement
transformé par le Sénat mais qui ne sera
pas celui que il ne sera pas celui que
le gouvernement retiendra et le
gouvernement fera du 49-3 à l'Assemblée
mais pour vous qu'est-ce qui ne va pas
dans ce budget
la philosophie de ce que vous allez
proposer nous avons déjà dit
soutenir le travail plus que
l'assistanat ça veut dire que si on veut
arrêter cet endettement ce déficit
considérable il faut remettre à plat un
certain nombre de choses il faut revenir
vraiment sur j'allais dire de la force
et plus sur du du solidaire mal fichu on
sait très bien qu'il faut revenir sur un
certain nombre de sujets un certain
nombre de de système sociaux qui ne
tiennent pas si la récession
arrive ça peut avoir un impact lourd sur
le budget si la hausse des prix devient
de plus en plus fortes et que la crise
énergétique moi je me souviens encore de
de Bruno Le Maire
et à l'époque avec Olivier du soft qui
nous disait que 2022 allait être une
année où on comptait faire en moyenne 5
à 6 % de croissance ou le déficit serait
réduit et on disait en 2023 c'est
terminé nous sommes à 3-4% de croissance
et on revient à 3% bon quand on voit la
réalité des choses on sait bien que
malheureusement subit les conditions
internationales ce sera le mot de la fin
c'est la fin de cette émission merci
beaucoup j'ai Carotti d'avoir lancé
cette nouvelle saison de Parlement Hebdo
et merci à vous tous de nous avoir
suivis et rendez-vous la semaine
prochaine pour les incontournables du
Parlement Ciao
[Musique]